parra très très sympa ça aussi c'est
sympa ce que vous allez apprendre sur
des générations qui cohabitent entre
elle et qu'on connaît pas forcément la
génération x y z virginie s'avoue pas
oui oui mais mais va envoyer d'accord
donc ça c'est diplomatique quoi et vous
sébastien juste de nom et donc on va
apprendre beaucoup de choses je mets
bien sûr qu'on va prendre beaucoup de
choses parce que l'avenir c'est eux la
génération x y z c'est nos enfants et
nos petits enfants va peut-être
commencer avec la génération x
qu'est ce que c'est que cette génération
en fait c'est celle après les baby
boomers dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure donc moi je fais partie c'est à
dire 46 75 à peu près enfin voilà
commence à partir de 1965 elle va
jusqu'à 1980 oui c'est ça c'est ça ma
fait oui en fait je me suis beaucoup
pencher là dessus dans la mesure où j'ai
une clientèle très diversifiée à la fois
dans le monde de l'entreprise et aussi
des gens que je viens qui viennent pour
travailler sur eux alors en clair et
pour nous qui vivons avec les
générations x y z c'est à dire des
enfants qui sonne entre 1965 et 1980 ce
avec un des grands enfants voilà j'aime
classés dans cette catégorie la nation x
s'il vous plaît on a grandi avec des
écrans d'ordinateur des consoles de jeux
vidéo ça veut dire que j'ai pas comme
les autres vous la sensation oui ce que
je veux dire c'est que si vous voulez la
génération x en fait et moi marquer
effectivement par par les écrans et tout
ce qui est digital que y z derrière je
vais dire oui bien sûr que ça a changé
notre vie mais nous étions au seuil de
la découverte ou cette affaire survient
généralement menées sur un corps sain je
veux dire avec eux comme nez avec le
monde voilà les générations qui suivent
elles elles sont vraiment enfin ils
baignent dedans donc ça change
effectivement les choses et ça change
aussi l'univers dans lequel on évolue
tous ensemble aujourd'hui d'accord on
continue à parler de la gp apr en
reviendra sur les puces et sur les moins
de ces générations qui sont là avec un
petit tableau qui explique bien la
génération y c'est ceux qui sont nés à
partir de 1981 jusqu'en 1995 oui c'est
cela oui tout à fait kate une génération
effectivement qui a beaucoup plu baigné
dans le digital fin très clairement mais
critique encore un peu charnière
par contre les aides
voilà on sait aujourd'hui que leur
univers effectivement enfin fonctionne
beaucoup avec les écrans enfin y'a pas
que ça non plus parce que enfin tout ça
détermine un certain nombre de
fonctionnement aussi dans leur vie au
quotidien et des grands changements
qu'on est obligé d'observer au niveau
social même évidemment voilà bien sûr on
dit d'eux vous m'arrêtez si je me trompe
que c'est la génération silencieuse
c'est vrai alors en partie parce que de
notre côté si vous voulez c'est une
génération très impatiente et qui très
souvent effectivement enfin propose
d'autres modes de vie sains pour les
aides à tout ce qui correspond au fait
de vivre ensemble en location de de se
déplacer en voiture commune d'être
effectivement dans des valeurs fortes en
chantant on est un petit jeune femme la
barre et 18 ans voilà l'engagement
donc elles sont peut-être silencieuse
dans leur vie en dans l'intimité
familiale peut-être bien plus que
d'autres ont pu l'être mais par contre
socialement parlant il ya il ya beaucoup
de choses à dire
or justement parlons-en c'est vrai que
le rapport au travail par exemple est
totalement différente
ces trois générations on a un petit
tableau là quand je vois la génération z
quand je regarde dans l'est moins il ya
des patrons qui doivent regarder qui
doivent se dire où la défiance
entreprises impatience dispersion des 8
août a fait honnêtement enfin c'est une
génération qui peut se sont positionnés
absolument m'effacer vraiment du jour là
c'est à dire que à les limites des
personnes qui vont faire des
remplacements des étudiants les choses
comme ça
et à un moment donné effectivement ça
leur des pieds elles ont même atteint à
carrefour en attend la caissière je veux
dire elle ne prévient même pas qu'elle
ne vient pas alors se veut pas dire que
tout les gens de la génération z sont
ainsi mais effectivement enfin nous les
baby boomers et la génération x
on avait quand même une certaine
représentation du monde du travail alors
que vision pyramidale si l'étude ne
alors que non là en fait c'est pas parce
qu'elle les galons qu'on envisage qu'on
respecte ans et la méritocratie qui est
au rendez vous et je te respecte sylt en
vaut la peine quoi c'est pas parce que
tu es le chef ça dessert vous au club
grec
mais quand vous vous retrouvez dans
cette génération difficultés avec la
hiérarchie instabilité qui libre pro et
personnels n'ont pas tellement
ça c'est l'émoi mais les plus ses fortes
capacités d'adaptation forte autonomie
forte maîtrise technologies oui on a
grandi avec les ordinateurs et vous
virgin et quelle génération z comme une
totale transparence
un réseau international ce qui m'a
beaucoup frappé effectivement dans ses
plus jeunes générations c'est qu'ils
vous disent moi j'ai pas envie de
réussir dans la vie
je voudrais réussir ma vie j'ai entendu
ce à plusieurs reprises l'an dernier et
je me suis dit mais enfin et pour tout
vous dire que j'en étais ravi parce le
cacher on a tous des enfants des petits
enfants
et quand ils nous regardent ils nous
prennent pour des extras sionisme à
temps mais pascal est a consacré toute
sa vie au boulot et non mais c'est fou
quoi il ya des fous le travail c'est pas
la victoire ce que c'est ça la veille tu
as rendu en famille vous dis là ce
serait pour le respect que le travail tu
as donné un sens à moi non équilibre pro
perso essentiel ouais ouais donc on n'a
pas de baguette magique pour les changer
parce qu'il s'agit pas de l'échangé
folie wazemmes qui vont nous changer
voilà parce que la voilà je voulais
simplement rassurer ceux qui sont avec
nous et moi le premier en me disant que
finalement c'était tout à fait normal si
deux fois les petites frictions
c'est qu'on n'est pas pareil bien
compréhension surtout auquel la
génération x y z
il représente en tout cas là la
charnière d'un siècle et à mon avis il
n'est que le début
parce que derrière z c'est parce que